I really want to start with a sincere uh
congrats I thought you did such great
work in this thank you very much thank
you that's very kind uh so uh you've
done some really cool work the last few
years and I'm just curious if someone's
actually never seen anything you've done
before uh what is the first thing you'd
like them watching and why
Ah that's a good question
well
you know like like I don't I don't want
them to not be intrigued about the
others so I think a good light one that
is fun
and enjoyable
and shows just how bizarre my choices
are would probably be I'd start them
with fighting with my family yeah that's
also quite good
yeah I think that's a it's a good one
that people can laugh at and be like oh
it's interesting jumping into why I get
to talk to you um trying to depict
Addiction on screen and make it
realistic uh it can be the third rail
because if it's not real this is a
disaster
um and so I'm curious was there any
hesitation on your part on playing this
role because it's you know it's going to
require a lot out of you and if it
doesn't work it's real bad yeah you're
right if it doesn't work it's offensive
it's disrespectful it's embarrassing
it's uh all the awful things that an
actor performer or a director never
wants to fail
um I think that's why it is so crucial
that we did
deep deep diving and deep background
checks on what it is that these people
are going through you can't make a movie
like this with this topic and this uh
this unbelievably sensitive and delicate
storyline without doing our research and
without talking to the right people and
that's just something that I you know it
was obvious that you need to do
for me
um as an actor I I need to get into the
physicalities of a character
um that's how I kind of get into who
they are and how they walk and how they
hold themselves and especially for
someone battling
um an opiate addiction I needed to
understand the drug I needed to
understand uh how it makes people feel
when they have it when they don't have
it how it affects your life
um in in all the positive and negative
ways and so that was something that I I
took very seriously
um and understanding the pain the sheer
physical pain that you are actually in
you know you need this thing and if you
have this thing everything is fixed and
you feel better and everything up until
that point of having it is Agony sheer
pain your skin is itching
um you are absolutely ill and the one
thing that can save you is this this
little thing and so for me uh yeah I
just I asked a lot the questions and
practice the physicality and I think
also just one more thing regarding
recovery like it's not it's not one
clean easy line of like oh you get to
Rock Bottom and then you fix yourself or
oh you're here and then you get worse
it's it's a roller coaster it's up it's
down there are Peaks there are troughs
it's never obvious what's going to
happen next and I think that's just so
important to highlight and especially in
our movie I think we do a good job of it
is that it's you you don't know which
way it's gonna go and that's why it's so
hard to overcome yeah there's a line in
the film uh I've I've known people with
addiction uh issues and there's a line
in the film where Zoe says to you uh you
know I've I've there are people that
have made it and there are other people
that have died and you know um and it's
very very accurate yeah you know
um uh when you were looking at the
schedule and you saw everything you had
to do what was the day you had circled
like oh this is going to be a really bad
day never oh really
never I
um I thrive under pressure
and I love being put to the test and I
completely come alive when we are
telling a story uh in a short amount of
time and I I love a uh a short shoot I
find it exhilarating and thrilling and
everybody is so focused because we need
to get it done and you know this is how
I I grew up in the industry This is How
I Learned was
small Indies with not a lot of time
tiny budget
an amazing cast at a fantastic crew and
you've just got to make it work and I
think for me I love that aspect of
filmmaking there's nowhere to hide
there's no day that you can figure
something out if you don't get it you
lose it from the movie and that's how I
learn and I uh I I really like stepping
up to the challenge with these kind of
movies what was it like filming The
Cutting actually yeah I was going to say
of The Cutting of your hair because you
obviously have like one take to get it
so excited I
dare I had that I wanted her to
I wanted us to meet her a year later and
her be a completely changed person and
her actually willingly chopping that
piece of herself off
um
and I was so pumped I was so excited to
chop it because then I really felt like
I could get into Allison like I knew
that once that hair was gone like I knew
exactly I felt her I was her
um and I was so excited to do it and I
was so excited to do it on camera Zach
was totally terrified I mean he the
morning of and the week before he was
trying to give me so many outs he was
like you know we can get a wig we could
do this you don't have to do it and I
was like nope I'm so excited to do it
and even on the day crew members were
coming up to me like are you sure you're
okay like are you sure you want to do
this and I was it was it was um
thrilling it was like it was we finally
got to be with the real Alison I'm just
about out of time with you but I am a
huge fan of Denis and Greg Frazier and
uh you got to collaborate with both on
the the Dune sequel I just want to know
what that experience was like and what
can you tease about arguably my most
anticipated film of the year I can't
tease anything other than the fact that
I feel very lucky to be a part of that
cast
um when I started meeting everyone I was
just taking everybody's faces in and
going oh my God
I'm doing it I'm here and um I have no
idea what it's like I have no idea how
the rest of the shoot went
um I'm just so thrilled to be a part of
it and that's unfortunately all I can
give you
it's totally cool um I can't wait to see
that film and again congrats on this
wish you nothing but the best thank you
so much thank you bye-bye